we are here in the kitchen and we're
about to make something delicious but we
need a little help and I was just
thinking maybe we should call on
somebody who is an actress a director an
absolute foodie someone who started
cooking at just six years old she's also
beautiful and amazing and I'm in love
with her it's Eva Long
Colombia
[Applause]
oh
you're really cooking oh yeah I'm really
cooking actually
um Eva has this extraordinary new
cookware line called Arisa which means
to laugh
I didn't know that yes to laugh because
I mean the kitchen's where we spend most
of our time laughing
so I'm gonna cook while Eva and I talk
and I'm going to try to do anything look
cool this is her recipe by the way I've
never made clams well I've I this dish I
actually feel comfortable with because
it feels so expensive and exquisite but
really it's actually economically
attainable and easy to make so I'm gonna
make you uh spaghetti and clams I know
we traditionally do it with linguine but
I actually really like a spaghetti
because some linguine can get a little
wide and doughy and I think it takes
away from the two of the clams and
spaghetti it's just I mean so this is
garlic and olive oil this is garlic and
olive oil see in the reset pan there's a
pan which by the way has even a
distribution of heat so there's no like
hot spots in your pan I'm so in love
with Eva's um cookware I'm gonna throw
in some butter because that gives the
fat I like butter in anything would you
um accompany me with the um chili flakes
and do it the way you would do it for
yourself oh like this I'm glad I just
got it in my soup wait I just got it in
myself yeah but you did that cool arm
thing yeah yeah so that's kind of
cooking down you give it a few minutes
you can kind of see and sense the
golden-ness don't let your garlic burn
it just tastes bad and it's not pretty
yeah so then I'm actually gonna put the
clams in which keep them chilled you
want to rub them a lot rinse them scrub
them if you need to store them clean
them clean them
um and then get your white wine in there
and literally that is it that is it it's
that easy and then you can actually
close it you cover that that gets
covered here oh well let's okay you know
yeah but just so you know too when
you're adding ingredients this um this
hooks onto the side oh my God that is so
cool I know I know this is the most
exciting thing
okay I am freaking out about your new
show searching for Mexico which if you
all know
this is a part of the Heritage and
Legacy brand on CNN searching for Italy
you are now taking the mantle yes and
carrying the torch and doing things
searching for Mexico I am so in love
with the show oh did you see it isn't it
so elegant yeah it's beautiful it's so
beautifully shot yeah and your clothes
in it
is so amazing you're like Ingrid Bergman
and Casablanca I love that you're coming
in with a popped collar and a white
cream it's not white it's cream which is
even more money yeah and these beautiful
pants and then you're like in the street
with a white like Grecian oh it's super
nice not a Grecian maxi dresses but you
know I used a lot of matte I used a lot
of Mexican designers because I wanted
the Mexican designers to get all my
jewelries Mexican everything I wear in
the show most of it is Mexican designers
it's so transported yeah
you feel about Eva's show when you watch
searching for Mexico it is warm it is
elegant it is inviting it is also it's
very it's super personal it's also very
diverse because Mexico's identity and
food is like tacos tequila tacos tequila
which it is and it does very well
um and I love but there's so much more
and we'd go through the whole country
and and it's just so diverse like it's
like a a jewel of gastronomy you're
gonna love the food porn it really is
mind-blowing I mean it's my new favorite
show I'm obsessed we're going to cut to
a quick commercial break and when we
come back you're gonna see oh these
babies that's what we're going to be
looking at
and we're gonna show you how easy this
dish is to make it even to live there
gorgeous cooking line Risa we will be
right back oh and we do kitchen
confessions with me yeah yeah
[Music]